this week on quadriga
turkey in turmoil a divided society a
wave of protests has swept across Turkey
police units have been cracking down on
demonstrators hundreds have been injured
and more than a thousand arrested there
have been major outbursts of violence in
Istanbul in Ankara and in dozens of
other cities across the country
it all started with a protest about
plans to build over a park by Taksim
Square in the heart of its temple
soon the protests had taken on a new
dimension were aimed at the ADA one
government as a whole so why are the
demonstrators so angry your host this
week peter craven our on a very warm
welcome to this latest edition of
quadriga where we're going to be
discussing the latest developments in
turkey protests the most dramatic and
the most serious in many many years in
the country as we've seen arrests
violence fatalities even where has it
all suddenly come from that's the
question we're going to be exploring
here today and to do so I've got three
excellent guests with me here in the
studio let me begin by introducing them
to her to you and the first person I'm
going to introduce to you is gut
challenge thank you very very much for
joining us today guchin now for several
years Gershwin was the editor of the
leading Turkish news magazine Yanni
actor well that was from 2006 until very
very recently she is still a freelance
journalist but she is also currently
writing a PhD focusing on Islamic and
secular policies in the late Ottoman
Empire and Turkish Republic interesting
stuff now my second guest is kübra goo
Masai she is a student of political
science based in Hamburg and in the
United Kingdom in Oxford to be precise
she's also an influential and well-known
blogger what's more her blog is focused
although not exclusively on what life is
like here in Germany and elsewhere for
Muslim women who choose to wear
headscarves and my third guest last but
not least as they say Marcus crime he is
from the German Institute for
International and security affairs his
area of expertise is defense and
security policy and especially nee tone
and that is very important for us of
course because Turkey has long been a
key member of the NATO military alliance
well welcome to all of you GUCH and I'd
like to begin with you with a simple and
straightforward question what is going
on in Turkey
to summarize it as France
straightforwardly turkey wants to stay
democratic the government was always
after the democratic values in Turkey
but now as approximately since two years
this attitude changed slowly and slowly
and there's increasing control over the
freedom of speech for instance over
Academy over press and over public
spaces
that's that fine I find it really
important and so people have waited and
waited doing nothing but at some point
it exploded because they felt that
nobody was listening to them there their
voices were not heard the government
especially mr. Arden was deaf like
towards them and the folk the ordinary
people in Turkey were really angry with
him so this actually these
demonstrations quite make it clear that
there is a strong civil society in
Turkey and they want to make clear that
they exist actually okay
one very interesting point they of
something that was new to me there or
not new but I really need to know you
said two years ago you said the Edwyn
government was associated with democracy
has been associated with democracy you
credited the government with that and
then you said two years ago the mood
began to change what happened two years
ago why that well two years ago actually
since twelve years our government is in
power but after it's a long process but
I believe after the demolition of the
country was complete it felt that they
have the power actually and they can do
whatever they
in the country since they have the
majority so this there is no one there
there was no one who could stop them
doing whatever they did the NGOs were
silenced non-governmental organizations
the press was put under control checked
came under increasing pressure yes
exactly exactly the military was not so
strong anymore the opposition party
that's a really big topic but the
opposition party was not making an
effective opposition
I would agree so since two years it has
it feels that it has totally power over
the whole country
kübra commissar you I was I saw you
nodding about a lot of what you've heard
and listened carefully to what you've
heard what's your take on it all yeah I
think I would also add that I think
another topic was that so I've been
talking to a few friends who've been
analyzing hair done for quite a long
time they've been saying he's got this
granddad mentality where he's like let
me give you an advice on something and
then it's something that that's very I'm
sort of personal and something a prime
minister should not be intervening in
such as you know abortion or how many
children you should have all kind of
bread you should eat and I think these
kind of things we've said made people
see him as someone who was trying to
intrigue in their to their personal life
as well so it wasn't just what you've
mentioned you know you know the policy
the opposition party not you know being
a real opposition to the society not
feeling being heard and media and that
sort of covering what people wanted them
to cover but also I think that they felt
there's sort of someone trying to
intrigue into their lives and and and
secondly what I've also been told and
what I sort of agree on us that he's got
this
street boy mentality right he's this
he's strong he's he's got this granddad
slash street boy thing where he's like
sometimes he can be very harsh right or
look angry and and somewhat firm but
I've got from people is that they have
also reacted to this they've also react
us to this anger with anger as well so I
think this is also on an emotional level
very important because those are hard
facts you're right but I think on an
emotional level there was also more
going on okay we're gonna be talking
about the personality the political
personality mr. ed one later a lot of
people outside Turkey have reduced this
to simply secular versus Muslim yeah
yeah are they right to do so oh not
definitely not I think this is also very
wrong because a Turkish society is
already a very polarized society you
have different political ideologies
interests and religious groups and if it
will be portrayed as something like that
it would totally sort of accelerate this
polarization and damage society in a
really bad way also I think this already
has happened during the protest because
there were people who were trying to
propagate others through false news on
both sides and I've just heard that a
few days ago thinking he's made a group
of Muslim women who were wearing the
hijab were attacked and their head
scarves were stripped off and and then
these kind of things will continue
happening if we keep on trying to create
you know black and white and I think
there are many people who support the
government but who also say there are
things I'm critical about this and I
want to be seen as someone who is
critical but also supportive and then
there are people who are saying again to
the government but I'm also interested
in a constructive debate so there's like
black and white and there's everything
in between the thousand shades of grey
probably okay so we don't want any black
and white that's one thing we've
established Marcus come let me ask you
it you know I'm gonna ask you my second
question as a security expert which is
what you are but first of all sort of
give me a personal take I know that a
lot of people in
side turkey but a lot of people in
Turkey in Istanbul specifically have
been comparing if they've used the words
Taksim Square and Tahrir Square in one
sentence yeah Tahrir Square where the
word were the revolution in Egypt came
to a head do you think as somebody who's
a person watching the news do you think
does that sound plausible to you I think
the the picture is a little bit more
complex here I think they may be ironic
development is that two years ago Turkey
and Prime Minister had one has been one
of the leading symbols for the for for
the uprising in the Arab world he was
praised in Egypt he was praised in
Tunisia and now and it's almost ironic
that he's now considered to be in Turkey
a similar situation like in Egypt a
similar situation in Tunisia and
regardless of any criticism and
regardless of the personality and the
political systems in Turkey I think it's
not really fair Turkey is a working
democracy I think maybe we have a weak
opposition which is not working
appropriately or as it should but we
have exactly as as you have liberated a
variety of public political opinions
which carry which can be expressed
freely you have checks and balances and
I think we have to take into
consideration that the other one
government managed something to do which
several governments meant Turkish
government's did not manage to do limit
the influence of the military which is a
tremendous achievement for for the
Turkish political system therefore
regardless of any criticism I think this
comparison is not really appropriate
important points important instant
insights and I see that you're both
nodding there as Marcus outlines all
that but fact remains that what we have
in Turkey at this point in time is an
ongoing situation it's a situation of
turmoil of upheaval turkey is an
important ally for Germany and an
important ally for NATO how concerned
should we be I think we shouldn't be
concerned about the pacific development
of the last days and week but so long as
the political system remains to be
stable
as far as I can see it's it's stable I
think the learning process will take
place or has to take place that
democracy in the eyes of other one has
not only to do bout having the majority
and keeping the majority the question is
how to cope with minorities but this is
not a question for the Alliance per se
and the what is more of concern for the
Alliance it's a situation the
turkish-syrian border and I'm pretty
sure that we're going to talk about
definitely okay duction and kübra yeah
Germany has a big Turkish community
people outside in the big wide world
know that and I'm sure they're very
interested to hear what you can tell us
about what is being said about the
latest developments in Turkey here in
Germany and Berlin and throughout the
country actually what can you tell us
I was already active in these
organizations around the demonstrations
and I would suggest the debate as you
said the Turkish community in Germany is
really diverse so there are different
opinions about what's going on there but
on the other hand just like in Turkey
this these demonstrations kind of United
people united people who would otherwise
not come together I was in these big
demonstration on last Saturday in
Kreuzberg and it was there was a tune
explained Kreutz back a very diverse
district to Berlin very famous for it
for having a very large Turkish
community yeah exactly exactly but the
interesting thing was many people who
were living outside Croats back a
Turkish a million people coming from
Turkey it also came to Kreuzberg with
their children with their mothers with
their old father's grandmother's
grandfathers and it's sort of United
people the left-wing for instance
Turkish people or the secular ones or
the nationalist ones so it's this anger
towards Iran was there visible also
because I think we'll talk about that
later but it nobody actually is
directing about attention to the
problems of the government and the
policies actually but the main symbol of
this these demonstrations of these
movements in Turkey is argon itself as a
person so it's it was really interesting
the March and I think that's the case
for Germany also it's the whole German I
mean they're having protests
protestations in other cities also and
you could see that the the diversity of
the crowds and about the Occupy
supporters I would say they are still
waiting to see what will go on in the
next few days yeah I think the sort of
thing I have a problem with is I don't
necessarily think that aired on is the
cause of the problem and also that's why
I've sometimes find it problematic when
he's seen as the sort of equivalent of
the problem and if he goes away the
problem will be solved because I think
this is a systemic problem that exists
in Turkey because like older people
remember how it was before I had done
was there before the AKP was in power
and and we always had a system whoever
was in power had also the power to
oppress people have had a different
opinion so I think so my public personal
stance on this for instance is I don't
think that this problem is linked to
specifically the AKP or Aragon I think
there's a systematic problem in Turkey
and that is whoever is in power has too
much power so I think in Turkey to make
it more democratic there has to be some
tools so that the opposition can be more
powerful and can can sort of interfere
more into this decisions that are taken
also civil society should have more
influence on certain topics so
I agree you're in our last analysis is
right that most people sort of see him
as this symbol but I find that
problematic I would I would say yes of
course the main problem of Turkey is
that whoever has the power has too much
power but occupies a success was part of
that's a point actually because he
promised to change the system he that's
why he got more than fifty percent votes
I mean not everyone who wanted for him
was a religious person as much as argon
for instance but he promised he argued
that the system was wrong in Turkey
but then after ten years he was more and
more becoming like the system itself
it's really problematic it's he can't
see what he has been through actually at
this point I think and for instance he
yeah yes we are coming to arrogance once
more but it's the weekend we can't
handle the situation without referencing
him actually and that's important also
that's an important point he he can't
stand any criticism he can't absolutely
and I know that not only outside rkp but
only within occupant occupy is also
dialogue it's an important point a lot
of people within his own AKP yeah the
party had been saying you know he's not
listening to us yeah exactly
and I'm also in close contact with not
only feminists and left wings in Turkey
but also religious people from other
tariqats and etc other religious groups
and they have been criticizing Aaron
really really I mean this could the
critics have been increasing in the last
two years more harshly than people you
would expect them from is that the end
of course there's this Gulen movement
effect also that the dichotomy like kind
of it's it was visible but then it was
it
it was made invisible sort of a sudden
so it's okay let's discover I want one
thing we've talked about that the word
diversity has been used a couple of
times let's just talk about give me a
quick assessment but of who is involved
in these protests because everybody I
need everybody I talked to here in
Germany sake you are they who are they
mainly young people aging from nineteen
to thirty yeah other than that feminists
house wise old people families and I
mean it are you saying because I think
this is an important point are you
saying westernized secular urban liberal
no I wouldn't make that argument because
for instance the anti couple of
capitalist Muslims are there also and
they are really their arguments are
really attracting audiences and last
night it was a holy a night in the
Muslim world and they were together in
the Taksim Square
and celebrated this holy night together
I mean it's it's not only secular urban
liberal people but also Muslims there
were many just one point there are many
women with head scars also so and so
what Cooper you're you're who are you
seeing when you when when you watch your
TV screen uh I don't watch TV but I know
what that is no but and what happened
last night for instance I found that
very symbolic and very positive sign as
well because that was basically saying
no matter I think I mean they're not
only you know Turkish people are not
only Muslim there are people who are
traditionally Muslim and religiously
Muslim and then also people who are just
of different you know who are Christians
Jews cetera and so I found that a you
know huge symbol to sort of say no
matter what background we have we will
now come here together here and
celebrate the site because we know it's
important to Muslim protesters or to the
Muslim population and I think it was
probably
so far the most effective way and saying
or we are not simply just the secular
Kemalists elite that you know people
were saying or talking about so in that
way I I found that a very positive sign
yeah it's interesting it you could
almost say that the protests are like an
advertisement for the diversity and
complexity of Turkish society like an
advertising campaign for the world
outside Turkey look at us yeah I think I
think it's like that and not that as
well because at the same time you know
we have these positive symbols but then
you also have you know false information
that are spread out for instance about
that mosque where apparently protesters
have been sort of hiding in and they've
been drinking beer and wearing shoes and
you know what you should do in the
mosque and left it dirty and then you
find out later on actually they weren't
drinking beer there the Imam there were
people who were sort of helping the
injured people and the Imams then
negotiated with the police so that the
protesters could live they leave the
building and happen so quick that they
didn't even have time to clean up so it
was just a very simple and basic
explanation to what had happened there
but those pictures had sparked so many
protests again and then you have the
other side where protesters are
spreading news about people that
apparently had died that you know there
are two people who have died but then I
think if you had been following all
those you know announcement of people
have died it would be like 50 something
and and also like that orange agent was
used that's a gas that is very dangerous
and also was used I think during the
Vietnam War by the US okay and so you
have at the one side on the one side the
huge option of sort of trying to show
how diverse and sort of how diverse the
Turk societies and how much they still
have in common and also you know how
this diversity is sort of shuffling them
apart okay because bring you in Marcus
crime and I'm very intrigued there was
one moment in the last week which I
thought was quite significant you've
talked very favorably of mr. Edwin and
some of his achievements in the security
and defense field foreign policy field
he reacted in one way that he reacted
- the protest was that he sat down he
gave a press conference and he said
foreign agents foreign influences are
involved here and I thought well that's
a sort of a pattern that we've seen in
Turkey in the in the past often I think
it's fair to say and I but I also
wondered at the same time what somebody
like you would say to that how plausible
that is who you know who these foreign
influences could be that he's referring
to I don't think then these foreign
influence exists in with regard to this
uprising the last week I mean this is
the usual explanation of maybe not an
autocratic ruler but Prime Minister
which is very self-confident having a
certain perception of democracy with our
already alluded to as a tool for him to
supply political power to him and and
his entourage and I cannot see how this
uprising has been sparked or influenced
by by foreign powers okay we'll talk
about the word the autocratic mr. wet on
we will come to it in just second but
there's one more thing I want to talk
about guchin
the the lady in red yeah we've got some
images I don't know of everybody who's
watching the program has necessarily
seen these images they you know they've
been very prominent in the Turkish media
let's have a look at them now and could
you just tell us what was actually
seeing there and why these are so
important
this was taken I believe on the first
time and of these gezi protests
protestations but what's important there
is that this woman was just walking
there she is a passive she isn't a
passive resistance day
so the she is when she's approaching the
police the police just a pepper gas is
her like as if I I'm sorry but as if she
is an insect I mean she is really their
passive and if you could see the power
of the state in in the body of this
policeman and the power and the tool for
this power with the pepper gas in this
picture
so well that it became a symbol actually
so but it's I think it's it has a lot to
do with this gendered aspect of these
demonstrations and the I mean there were
many many people women in these
demonstrations also for instance gay
people homosexual people were there also
so this feministic and gendered a aspect
of these demonstrations was was really
connected with that picture what that
picture showed actually you you were
saying for instance I'd gone as the
grandfather I think he is that he is
like I mean grandfather is not like the
father the father has more authority on
his family so Aragon is like the father
and here as a symbol of this patriarchal
state father the police and the pepper
gas over woman especially because you
know he's been really obsessed with this
street children and the abortion debates
with the devil really problematic he I
mean the do voices of feminist NGOs in
Turkey they they weren't totally heard
and nobody cared about the what woman
actually living in Turkey I thought
about these issues
kübra well what could you add to that oh
when I was following of those I because
I would also I'm very much into
feminists of AIDS I sort of agreeing I
mean it created its party debate that
wasn't necessary and I was quite happy
that no rule or no certain law was
passed after this debate and but again
it showed to me it was like this let me
give you this advice thing he had and
not like yeah let me pass a law so that
that's why I agree with you and then I
would I also think that due to that
nothing has happened after that no law
was passed it was fine but yeah I'm
basically I am okay feminists and Jews
just one point feminists angels are
arguing and actually have proved that in
practice abortion
cannot be is not possible in state
hospitals in Turkey that's a really
important thing okay
we've mentioned the Prime Minister I
chipped I better when he's obviously
absolutely central to everything but or
wherever he's naughty once again mister
everyone yeah let's we'll talk about him
in just a second in more detail let's
just first have this report on what he's
up to at this point in time as the
protests raged across Turkey
Prime Minister air21 headed off to North
Africa opponents say that's just another
example of his high-handed style he's
won a string of elections with his
moderate Islamism supporters point to a
track record of economic success
critics say he's trying to impose
Islamic values and is increasingly
authoritarian he's taken a hard line on
the demonstrations denying that they're
a valid form of democratic protest well
I assume that those who failed to defeat
us in democratic elections are trying to
defeat us now using these methods I'm
opening your gun
Edwin's confident the majority of Turks
are behind him and he's got no desire to
compromise with those that aren't Marcus
came it's very interesting that a with
the country in turmoil as it is mr.
Edwin jumps on a plane and goes
somewhere else yeah tell us a little bit
more about him your assessment of him
from the foreign policy perspective
maybe it's not such a foreign policy
perspective but if you compare the
pictures we have seen to the pictures of
Cairo of Tunis I think there's a knot
similarity in substance but in some
where similarity and the symbols and I
think we shouldn't underestimate the
pictures we have just seen the women in
red being pepper sprayed by the police
and with the second factor here
Prime Minister other one having left the
country will not being present it Ellis
traits from my point of view two things
first he has no feeling for how a
political system with with powerful
minorities driven by civil society works
and he has no feeling for how how
important these pictures are and how to
influence pictures especially given the
experiences of Tahrir Square Cairo of
Tunis I think the the drive or the main
point for government is to be we should
avoid any pictures we have seen like
this please attacking woman and so on
but he's I think he's as simply
underestimated and he has no feeling
what has really happened there
how should NATO be responding to what is
happening because I think it's fair to
say that in the last 10 years in the
air21 period from the EU perspective we
have been quite critical of you know
things like encroachments on press
freedom from the NATO perspective I
think we've tended to look at mr. Waldo
an and think he's a very solid person to
have an office in Ankara and and maybe
the time has come to be a little bit
more critical absolutely NATO is
has become member of NATO 1952 and it
has been important for two reasons first
the geostrategic position during the
Cold War the southern flank of the
Soviet Union and today if at least some
observers considered as some kind of
bridge to the Middle East so by having
NATO inside the Alliance you can somehow
influence things going on in the Middle
East second thing we have to keep in
mind in Turkey is more than 700,000
soldiers under arms being the or having
the second largest army inside NATO
after the United States so when we're
talking about any military operation
speed with regard to Syria or some some
some other place turkey isn't is an
important important player especially
given the the financial constraints most
other NATO members are facing
kübra I want to bring it back to mr.
Huerta one in you are I mean you're
you're you're a good deal younger than I
am yeah and you are a member of what I
suppose people would call and have
called the generation aired one yeah how
does that feel he's the only leader the
only Turkish leader that you've known in
your adult life that's what I'm getting
at yeah well but also I know how it was
before through the stories and through
the experiences of my parents and and
elderly people around who were tallying
how what they have suffered from and and
I think it was a lot present as well in
my case because my mom couldn't study at
university because she was wearing the
hats cough and I had many cousins who
couldn't do that until recently as well
so so it was very present to me and also
looking at you know my
great-great-grandfather and what they
have been through in Turkey I sort of
see a lot of improvement and and
personally I think that Iran was so far
the best president Turkey has ever had
and the improvements he's made are just
you know unimaginable every year I went
to Turkey to stay for a few months I was
just in awe how much had changed within
that year and how much the country had
improved so I definitely give him credit
for that but I think to keep that going
on to keep that level of development
going on he has to listen to what the
people are saying
and to what you've mentioned right that
there there are people who feel they
aren't heard and that's going to cause
problems in the future and that's going
to be very problematic I think one sort
of thing that symbolizes this is that he
said that I think Twitter is the Menace
or something and and then you feel like
well this plays a huge role especially
in Turkey I mean Turkey I think half of
the population is online six is sixteen
six percent sixteen and six percent of
the population that is online is on
Twitter so are things like seven million
something and if you watch Turkish TV if
you watch Turkish soap operas you will
always see a hashtag and so people are
sort of you know encouraged to debate on
Twitter online what's going on in Turkey
so it's very present and and a lot of
debates are going on on Twitter it does
play a huge role and for the president
sort of not really getting the idea of
how important that is
that is a strategist I apologize for
doing so but it is important to
establish prime minister Edwyn at this
point in time because obviously he
aspires to become the president and
that's an accomplice
in this whole plot at this point in time
yeah I'd like to it's fascinating what
you're saying that you're talking about
mr. Duan everybody who's been to Turkey
in recent years has seen the country
this immense modernization yeah and all
that is associated with mr. arrow and is
the fact of the matter now that he has
overstayed his welcome
or are we did the demonstrators now want
him to reform and continue I would not
totally agree about the modernism about
Turkey getting more modern because
that's something really problematic it's
he is privatizing public spaces and
instrumentalizing them so it's these he
acts as if these public spaces in not
only in Istanbul in text but also in
Ankara and in other cities these public
spaces belong to our key
and the government and he has the right
to do whatever he wants there I say he
wants because that's the second problem
although he is the prime end Prime
Minister right he is the Prime Minister
but he acts as the as if he is the mayor
of Istanbul he can't stay away from
Istanbul I mean he has to he has this
strong urge to have control all over the
country I mean one of the central
arguments of Occupy government was that
the local administration was to be
strengthened am i right
I mean it's really private Turkey is a
big country and the local administration
is weak so that caused problems because
you can't manage to have a society
directed from just one centre so it's a
it he's gone the other way he did he did
not support at all these local
administrative powers but he he on the
other hand decided to put have all the
powers in in him he even I mean with
these demonstrations did we see for
instance a mayor of Istanbul or Ankara
they were Ankara makers was he was
treating with hate and the the governors
of cities were not there I mean every a
country cannot be a government with only
one man it's it's it's impossible so and
Turkey is big and in a country as
diverse as Turkey that doesn't work and
we see that it's obvious okay so I think
the the next question is what happens
next what should happen next
Marcus cameras begin with you with
regard to foreign and security policy I
think okay yeah yeah I think it's it's
it's it's crucial how things play out in
Syria
in the next couple of weeks and month
and it's pretty obvious that Turkey has
overplayed the they can't that given the
fact that two years ago Turkey was
considered to be the not the hegemon but
the leading power the power where
everybody else is orienting to this
times are over the times of Neil Osmond
ISM so that Turkey would play the would
follow the old Ottoman Empire not in but
in classic imperii ruling but being a
poll where everybody's attracted to I
think this this this expectation has not
been fulfilled and the one of the
crucial question will be what happens to
Syria are not so much in political terms
but even in territorial terms if sorry
Syria falls apart as a political entity
my take is that the Turkish domestic
politics will will be phased not only
with the humanitarian problems which are
associated or which can be seen already
today but also with the question of what
are we going to do with the Kurdish
question and what are we going to do
with some areas which are at least
currently liberated by the Syrian rebels
and that might turn to Turkey and maybe
even at the end of the day they ask for
some kind of association to Turkey so
that will be very interesting to see how
this will play out person as you thought
kübra what should what what would you
like to see happening next yeah like I
won't know I didn't know what's going to
happen but I have a few hopes and that
is I think the protests have shown as
we've mentioned before a few times but
again there are there's a huge part of
the population that does not feel that
it's hurt that their needs are being
heard that what they want is some sort
of you know interest and so definitely
what the opposition needs to do is seize
that see that as you know some part of
sort of power to see alright there is
you know we could be a more
powerful opposition we could be doing
better or positional of work I think
that's important for democracy a good
opposition and and the government the
current government to really listen to
what's happening really try to get an
idea of what people want and try to be
constructive try to look for dialects or
a dialect talk to the protesters find
out what they would can be to because
they are right in their criticism in
terms of his authoritarian style of
ruling the country and all these things
we've mentioned before so I think that
needs to be listened to but I really
don't hope that so what I would fear is
that the country would go into a chaotic
state where those protests never end and
the only sort of end of those protests
would be aired on to step down because
in a democracy you elect and you don't
elect if you don't want that person to
empower okay duction the country from
where you left democracy is being
perceived in Turkey like voting every
four or five years that's not democracy
democracy is having the right to say
something about issues that about issues
about the public actually so I think
this definition of democracy should
change in Turkey first of all but I
believe it totally depends on the
attitude of the government and are done
specifically if they handle the
situation like they have done until now
I think the demonstrations will go on he
some argue that he is waiting that the
demonstrations will decrease and they he
will have the chance to marginalize them
I don't believe that's the case great
stuff thank you go changing thank you
very much for your contribution to
today's debate excellent stuff Cobra
homicide thank you very much deep Marcus
crime wonderful I hope we've given you
at home plenty of food for thought I've
certainly enjoyed the show if you've
enjoyed it as much as I have then do
join us next week on another edition of
quadriga until then bye bye
you